nevada highway patrol was partnering  with by talent to host a blood drive  this week so it's in honor of trooper  micah may the drive runs tomorrow from  10 a.m to 5 p.m at nhp headquarters near  sunset and decatur appointments are  suggested but they will have walk-in  appointments  available for you if you want to walk on  in and so nhp also teaming up with the  injured police officers fund to  have a donation drive on thursday is  from 9 to 2 at nevada coin mark t-shirts  and masks will be on sale and proceeds  will benefit the family of trooper micah  may  who was killed trying to stop a  carjacking suspect during an i-15 car  chase and so he was 46 years old and  survived by his wife and two young  children